he is in Atlanta all right Nicki how are
you I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's up well my husband and I
are just well we're sick and tired of
being normal actually hosted an FPU
class in our church this past May and we
started the budget and it put me in
paralyzed mode because we were behind
and so we just didn't do it and we've
continued to live above our means and
Christmas proved that we can't do it
anymore and then also my tail is
decreased several months ago back in
September and so we started to every
dollar budget and we're behind about a
month
what on every bill that we have just
about for the month so it's like a whole
month of bills that we're that are
months behind them paying
retrospectively gotcha so we're about
$3,600 mm-hmm well Charles our learning
time roughly 80,000 mm-hmm and you did
the every dollar budget just like this
week for January yes and you didn't do
one for December do you want to face it
then
correct and so how much do you owe in
your cars we have two cars one is about
16,000 and the other one is 1800 which
got about four more payments and I'll be
paid for that's good news it's a yeah
it's a 2006 it's built on that's still
going so I'm keeping it that's no that's
fine and so what other debts do you have
not counting your home we don't have a
mortgage for renting so that's for you
behind on the wait yes it's at that 30
days
so on so you can rent you got two car
payments and you have how much in credit
card debt fourteen thousand total mm-hmm
how much is student loan debt No
okay what are there 14,000 and medical
and then about 4,500 and some child
support arrears from previous marriage
years ago that's still sitting but that
hasn't been a cash flow issue for a
while right you know I paid on it in a
while okay let's say you're behind all
of your behind on the cars you're behind
on the rent you're behind the credit
cards you're behind on your utilities
right okay so your take-home pay is what
a month combined about 39 that's not
right
3900 no no I'm sorry about about 47 I'm
looking at different figures here you're
making 80 a year you told me right so
your take-home pay should be over $5,000
a month okay well I'll tell you if my
husband is self-employed barber and he
just recently opened a new shop within
the past six months so I'm having a hard
time figuring yes because it's irregular
so but my take-home pay alone is about
134 and then also get child support and
then plus his I'm averaging about a
thousand a month at the bare minimum so
okay all right yeah you should if you're
making $80,000 a year your take-home pay
after taxes should be in excess of 5,000
and so have you got you got 401 K coming
out at work no I do not I stopped it
okay do you have any other miscellaneous
junk coming out of work that's not
health insurance life insurance okay
the first thing is you're gonna have a
huge garage sale right the second thing
is is you're gonna have to prioritize
and not pay some things so that you get
current on the most important things
first it's ludicrous that you all make
as much money as you make and you're
behind on your
and your food in your cars and your
lights okay so here's your priorities
okay
nothing gets paid until you bought food
then nothing gets paid
you got money left after that nothing
gets paid until you've got your
utilities current then nothing gets paid
until you've got your rent current then
nothing gets paid you're following this
yes until your cars are current now
we've got food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities the basic
necessities of life are taken care of
you're current on all of those you're
not going to get thrown out in the
street your car's not gonna get repo'd
but you're probably further behind on
the medical bills and the credit cards
and they're all screaming at the top of
their lungs and I don't give a rip okay
okay right I'm gonna get to them but
they're by far less important than your
rent and your lights and your water and
you make way too much money right to be
this broker you cannot go to a
restaurant ever again unless you're
working there until this mess is cleaned
up you guys eat out all that time we did
we haven't and a few weeks okay you're
done I'm not going on vacation you're
broke right okay and we're not doing
anything except working in any any extra
that your husband can do to create some
money with these two barbershops
he needs to be doing it it needs to be
working all the time big garage sale
this Saturday a whole bunch of crap you
bought at Christmas probably needs to go
back and be turned into cash right so my
question with the baby steps after we're
not - baby steps yet we got to get your
current before you start the baby steps
so current on just the basics or
everything all the credit cards every
round you get current on them you're
only a month behind
$3,000 brings you current you've blown
$3,000 in the last 60 days right you
have no idea where $3,000 went in the
last 60 days
and so in the next 60 days you're gonna
find that plus stay current and you'll
be current we're gonna get your current
first it's gonna take two months okay
depending on how much this garage sale
brings in and how much extra work your
husband gets and creates lots of people
need to get their hair cut immediately
all right
okay and we just got to get with it here
we got to make some money we got to lean
in and then prioritize most important
thing is what dude
then utilities then rent then car do not
ever be late on your utilities again the
rest of your life making $80,000 a year
that's ridiculous do not ever be rent
late on your rent again the rest of your
life that's ridiculous
okay because what you did was you paid
the stupid credit cards I still paying
the rent
thank you that way and that's what I'm
saying that's why I'm saying it's
ridiculous the money is there y'all make
the money you've just been disorganized
and you were running around putting out
fires from one fire to the other one
fire to the other one fire to the other
and then the things turned into a
bonfire on you all right it's caught up
and hit you so you can do this you can
do this if you're desperate enough to
finally stop doing the stupid you can
turn this around you have the
mathematical ability and I think I hear
it in your voice that you're ready
definitely ready is he ready is he he
says he is not sure if he's as ready as
I am then I'm telling me the dog needs
to be hiding because you're selling so
much stuff yeah Craigslist is your new
friend right cuz I'm tired of being
broke making $80,000 a year and you're
broke yep you know it's awful I'm sorry
I'm not picking on you I feel for you
and I want you next Christmas you need
to be completely debt-free a hundred
percent debt-free except your house and
you don't own the house so you'd be
hundred percent debt-free by Christmas
that's how much you can move the needle
on this it's only thirty thousand bucks
you make a tea and you're debt-free
you'll be there I mean you're right I
mean because you're gonna be working
like crazy and you're gonna go to
scorched earth on the lifestyle and
we're going to turn this thing around
you can have your life back I mean think
about what it would be like right now to
have no payments but the rent you'd have
so much room in your budget that's where
you'd be and go back through Financial
Peace University again it's free you
mean you bought you've joined it so
you've already joined it so go through
it again and get that on your side this
time you're ready and that that's you
call me if you need some more help you
got this though kiddo you can do this
but you're gonna have to get sick and
tired of being sick and tired I can't do
it for you this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]